the basic breakthrough of this vehicle
is the way it drives it tilts and that's
why we can make an airplane stable on
the road my name is Robert Ingham on so
I'm the CEO of the company Bell V and we
developed the first flying car in the
world the idea came from a frustration
that one of my partner he started flying
and flying is cumbersome you take over
the place where you don't want to leave
you enter the place where you don't want
to be the vehicle is built within
existing regulations so there's one OK
from a US and Europe and one OK from the
road authorities in Europe and then it
can be sold and have any European
country for driving you need your
driving license for cars and for flying
you need a TTL or RPL recreational pilot
license for a gyrocopter starting price
will be 300 thousand euros for the
general version there's a sort of
limited collector's edition for half a
million
we have interests from policing military
organisations eight organizations own
and security so and who knows in future
new technology gives new possibilities